it's been hardened enemy show
Assenmacher is testing a Honda clarity
her first fuel cell powered car in
Denmark because it's the European
country with the best network of
hydrogen gas stations but simple
declarative fuel set the Japanese car
maker has developed a vehicle that
produces no toxic emissions runs on
electricity recharges rapidly and has
the range of a gasoline or diesel
powered vehicle all the advantages and
none of the disadvantages of a
conventional internal combustion engine
when destined Michele's first impression
of a Honda clarity fuel cell is very
good the interior is attractive and the
car is very comfortable and quiet
Honda's environmentally-friendly
flagship as an elegant stately design
[Music]
ultra-thin LED headlights underscore the
futuristic appearance that we can expect
from Honda models in the future the fuel
cell stack has been reduced in size so
now it fits in the engine compartment
the Honda clarity is all about
aerodynamics special alloy wheel rims
and the hatchback roofline reduce wind
resistance air curtains let the air
stream smoothly past the wheel arches
hundra to improve the clarity zero
dynamics Honda has added air intakes in
front and back says Michelle air streams
in at the front and leaves again through
an opening at the back past the wheel
that means less air turbulence the
clarity has room for five people the
back seat has ample space
but the trunk is a real problem the two
big hydrogen tanks leave only 334 liters
of space for cargo and the backseat
can't be put down almost 80% of the
interior surface consists of
environmentally friendly materials the
dashboard and the interior cladding on
the doors are made of recycled polyester
plant materials are used for the floor
mats and roof lining if I did mess
as with most alternative power systems
this car is very quiet to drive says
Michelle the transmission is direct and
Michelle especially likes that the car
coasts rather than starting to break as
soon as she takes her foot off the gas
all sports how does a fuel cell car work
actually to make it simple a fuel cell
car is an electric car that doesn't need
to be plugged in it has its own power
plant onboard in the fuel cell stack in
the engine compartment
oxygen and water react producing
electrical energy and the ash from this
oxidation is pure water a turbo
compactor pumps air and with it oxygen
through the fuel cell the hydrogen comes
from 2 pressure tanks dustin refueling
the honda clarity is just like refueling
a car with a gasoline engine sense
michelle open the latch and lower this
little switch and set the fuel nozzle on
it
when you secure the lever air is shot
into the tank to measure how full it is
and how much hydrogen needs to be added
filling up takes about three minutes the
full cells and a buffer battery under
the front seats produce a maximum of 130
kilowatts and 300 Newton meters of
torque when the car slows or breaks
energy is recouped in the battery like
in a normal electric car
[Music]
Honda says one tank of hydrogen will
take the clarity more than 700
kilometers but 600 or 650 kilometers is
probably more realistic the car
accelerates from 0 to 100 in 9 seconds
[Music]
by bostonia when you accelerate says
Michelle you can really hear the car
sucking in air from the outside maybe
you can't hear it well in this film but
here inside the car it sounds strange
but it pretty cool when you step on the
gas a hissing sound drowns out the hum
of the electric motor that's compressed
air being forced into the fuel cell and
water vapor leaving the car through the
underbody the Honda clarity won't be
seen on German streets in the near
future there simply aren't enough
hydrogen service stations Honda is one
of five car manufacturers taking part in
the initiative
hi-five which wants to promote knowledge
and acceptance of fuel cell technology
you